SPEECH.
GOOD NIGHT FROM NORMANDY.
WE WILL BE BACK IN THE MORNING.
>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELCOME TO TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT.
BACK WHEN HE WAS A STAR ON
MSNBC, THIS SHOW WAS WARNING
AMERICA ABOUT THE CREEPY PORN
LAWYER.
NOW HE COULD BE DISBARRED.
FIRST TONIGHT LET'S BEGIN WITH
AN EXPERIMENT.
WHAT IS THE REPUBLICAN
LEADERSHIP IN WASHINGTON
BOTHERED TO LEARN THE LESSONS OF
THE 2016 ELECTION?
WHAT THIS THEY CARED ENOUGH TO
DO THAT?
WHAT THIS THEY UNDERSTOOD AND
EMBRACED THE ECONOMIC
NATIONALISM THAT WAS AT THE
HEART OF DONALD TRUMP'S
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN?
WHAT WOULD THE WORLD LOOK LIKE
NOW 2.5 YEARS LATER?
REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS WOULD BE
SAYING THINGS LIKE THIS:
"I AM DEEPLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITIES AMERICA HAS GIVEN
ME."
COMPANIES WAVE THE FLAG BUT HAVE
NO LOYALTY TO AMERICA.
LEVI'S OPERATES ONLY 2% OF THEIR
COMPANY HERE.
PENCIL PRODUCTION WAS MOVED TO
MEXICO AND CHINA AND GENERAL
ELECTRIC SHUTDOWN A FACTORY IN
WISCONSIN AND SHIPPED THE JOBS
TO CANADA.
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON.
THESE AMERICAN COMPANIES SHOW
ONLY ONE REAL LOYALTY.
TO THE SHORT TERM INTEREST OF
THEIR SHAREHOLDERS, A 3rd OF
WHOM ARE ATTORNEY INVESTORS.
THEY SHIP JOBS OVERSEAS TO SAVE
A NICKEL THEY WILL ABANDON LOYAL
AMERICAN WORKERS.
POLITICIANS LOVE TO SAY THEY
CARE ABOUT AMERICAN JOBS, BUT
THOSE SAME POLITICIANS HAVE
CITED FREE MARKET PRINCIPLES AND
REFUSED TO INTERVENE FOR
AMERICAN WORKERS.
THEY PROTECT THE INTEREST OF
MULTI--NATIONAL COOPERATIONS.
MILLIONS OF GOOD JOBS LOST
OVERSEAS AND A GENERATION OF
STAGNANT WAGES.
IF WASHINGTON WANTS TO PUT A
STOP TO THIS, IT CAN.
IF WE WANT FASTER GROWTH AND
MORE GOOD AMERICAN JOBS, THEN
OUR GOVERNMENT SHOULD DO WHAT
OTHER LEADING NATIONS DO AND ACT
AGGRESSIVELY TO ACHIEVE GOALS
INSTEAD OF CATERING TO THE
FINANCIAL INTEREST OF COMPANIES
THAT HAVE NO ALLEGIANCE TO
AMERICA.
WASHINGTON POLICIES ARE A KEY
DRIVER OF THE PROBLEMS AMERICAN
WORKERS FACE.
FROM TRADE AGREEMENTS TO TAX
CODE WE ENCOURAGE COMPANIES TO
DO BUSINESS OVERSEAS AND KEEP
WAGES LOW.
IT'S EASIER AND EASIER TO SHIFT
CAPITAL AND JOBS FROM ONE
COUNTRY TO ANOTHER.
THAT'S WHY OUR COUNTRY HAS TO
CARE MORE ABOUT DEFENDING AND
CREATING AMERICAN JOBS AND NOT
LESS.
WE CAN NAVIGATE THE WAY AHEAD
MAKING AMERICAN WORKERS OUR
HIGHEST PRIORITY.
LET'S SAY YOU REGULARLY VOTE
REPUBLICAN.
ASK YOURSELF:
WHAT PART OF THE STATEMENT YOU
JUST HEARD DID YOU DISAGREE
WITH?
WAS THERE A SINGLE WORD THAT
SEEMED WRONG TO YOU?
PROBABLY NOT.
HERE'S THE DEPRESSING PART:
NOBODY YOU VOTED FOR WOULD EVER
SAY.
THAT REPUBLICANS WOULD NOT
PROMISE TO PROTECT AMERICAN
INDUSTRY.
IT MIGHT ALIENATE THE LIB
TIREIANS.
A REPUBLICAN DID NOT SAY THAT.
SADLY.
INSTEAD.
THE WORDS YOU JUST HEARD ARE
FROM SENATOR ELIZABETH WARREN OF
MASSACHUSETTS.
IT'S TRUE.
YESTERDAY WARREN RELEASED HER
PLAN FOR ECONOMIC PATRIOTISM.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
THIS IS NOT A WORD ABOUT
IDENTITY POLITICS IN THE
DOCUMENT.
NO HYSTERICS ABOUT GUN CONTROL
OR CLIMATE CHANGE OR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
IT'S JUST ABOUT PRESERVING GOOD
PAYING AMERICAN JOBS.
MANY OF WARREN'S POLICIES MAKE
OBVIOUS SENSE.
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT SHOULD BUY
AMERICAN PRODUCTS AND IT SHOULD.
WE NEED MORE WORKPLACE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
WE SEE AMERICAN COMPANIES TAKE
RESEARCH AND USE IT TO
MANUFACTURE PRODUCTS OVERSEAS
LIKE APPLE DID WITH THE iPHONE.
SHE SOUNDS LIKE DONALD TRUMP AT
HIS BEST.
WHO IS THIS ELIZABETH WARREN YOU
ASK?
WELL, NOT THE GUN GRABBING
ABORTION EXTREMIST YOU THOUGHT
YOU KNEW.
ELIZABETH WARREN IS STILL ALL OF
THOSE THINGS TOO.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
NOT JUST FOR ELIZABETH WARREN
BUT WITH AMERICAN POLITICS.
IN WASHINGTON ALMOST NOBODY
SPEAKS FOR THE MAJORITY OF
VOTERS.
YOU ARE EITHER A LIBERTARIAN
ZEALOT CONTROLLED BY THE BANKS
TALKING ABOUT CUTTING
ENTITLEMENT.
OR WORSE YOU ARE A DECK  TRUST
FUND SOCIALIST.
WHAT THERE IS NOT IS A CAUCUS
THAT REPRESENTS FROM MOST
AMERICANS ARE.
FAIRLY TRADITIONAL ON THE SOCIAL
ISSUES.
IMAGINE A POLITICIAN WHO WANTED
TO MAKE YOUR HEALTH CARE CHEAPER
BUT WAS NOT EXCITED ABOUT
PARTIAL BIRTH ABORTION AND
RESPECTED THE NUCLEAR FAMILY BUT
WAS WILLING TO TAKE YOUR SIDE
AGAINST CREDIT CARD COMPANIES
BLEEDING YOU DRY AT 35%
INTEREST.
WOULD YOU VOTE FOR SOMEBODY LIKE
THAT?
OF COURSE YOU WOULD.
WHO WOULDN'T?
THAT CANDIDATE WILL BE ELECTED
IN A LANDSLIDE.
EVERY SINGLE TIME.
YET THAT CANDIDATE IS THE
OPPOSITE OF EVERYONE CURRENTLY
SERVING IN OUR CONGRESS.
OUR LEADERSHIP CLASS REMAINS
LIBERTARIAN.
COMMITTED TO THE RHETORIC OF
MARKETS WHICH IT SERVES THEM.
LIBERTINE ON QUESTIONS OF
CULTURE.
REPUBLICANS WILL LECTURE ABOUT
PAY DAY LOAN SCAMS.
JUST LAST WEEK THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCED A NEW
WAY TO PROTECT AMERICAN WORKERS
FROM THE TIDAL WAVE OF CHEAP 3rd
WORLD LABOR FLOODING THIS
COUNTRY.
WE WILL IMPOSE TARIFFS ON ALL
MEXICAN GOODS.
THAT IS WHAT YOU MIGHT PROPOSE
TO PROTECT YOUR COUNTRY.
THE DEMOCRATS OPPOSED.
IT THEY DON'T PRETEND TO CARE
ABOUT AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HERE'S WHAT REPUBLICANS SAY.
>> YOU TALK TO ALL OF OUR
MEMBERS, WE ARE NOT FANS OF
TARIFFS.
WE HOPE THIS CAN BE AVOIDED.
>> Tucker: WE ARE NOT FANS OF
TERRORISTS.
-- TARIFFS.
IMAGINE A MORE INFURIATING
RESPONSE.
YOU CAN'T BECAUSE THERE IS NOT
ONE.
MITCH MCCONNELL SAID THIS MIGHT
WORK IN PRACTICE BUT WE ARE
AGAINST IT BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
WORK IN THEORY.
THAT'S THE REPUBLICAN PARTY